a lot of times on K Tik Tok I just see
these like crazy conspiracy theories
about me or just all these people just
you know I'm not too popular on Tik Tok
I guess but there was a woman um that I
guess destroyed me I guess I have been
destroyed on Tik Tok and I'm very
excited to see it I guess she gave me
some Lo logic and facts and I'm super
excited to see it enlighten me feminist
know the people that believe in divorce
go be in long-term relationship ship
leave marriage for the people that
actually believe in For Better or For
Worse for richer or for poor in sickness
and in health till death do us hard do
you know what drives me nuts about this
clip that she's operating off a premise
that women are getting married with the
intention of getting divorced but
they're not making commitments with the
intention of breaking them they're just
making commitments to men who are
careful not to reveal themselves until
after the wedding is over and that
happens because of how seriously women
take their commitments they fight so
hard to keep their families together and
and they've been conditioned to be the
one who feels fault if it fails and
people can end up taking advantage of
that women end up staying when they
should probably leave because they've
been sold the myth of the infamous rough
patch and they keep telling themselves
it will get better despite the fact that
it keeps getting worse they sacrifice
themselves for what they've been told is
the good of the family so these women
end up being abused because of how
sacred they hold their vows and yet you
have the audacity to act like they're
just walking away like it means nothing
they're not just walking away because
he's poorer than the day they met in
fact she usually gets a second job if he
loses his and continues to cook dinner
nightly and that's also why she hasn't
had her nails done in 7 years if you
even bother to ask her marriage vows me
so much to so many people but you do not
stand on an altar and say For Better or
For Worse and to my own destruction
women stay for the love they have for
who that man used to be or because their
family threatens to disown them or
because a church told them that that's
their Duty or because they have a child
who looks up at them and asks them where
daddy is at bedtime this is not as easy
as you make it out to be and you need to
stop shaming people for living a life
you've never lived you don't get to
interpret someone's vows unless you've
walked in their shoes and lived with
their partner behind clothes doors
because For Better or For Worse should
never mean staying in a situation that's
worse than you ever could have imagined
what
what well let me let me get this
straight For Better or For Worse
should not mean staying in a situation
that is worse than you imagine well when
women imagine that marriage is going to
be this Disney fairy tale that's so
amazing and
awesome of
course I expect them to stay together
even if it's worse than they imagined so
let's let's go through her claims okay
because I wrote some of these down one
women are not getting abused left right
and Center no no no no no no that is not
the case and I will have to beat this
out of you guys no stop saying that
women are the more likely party to be
abused most abusive situations the
parties are abusing each other sorry
guys but you attract what you are if you
are constantly attracting abusive
Partners it is possible that maybe you
are abusive as well when it comes to
one-sided abuse where one party is
hitting the other and they are not
reciproca
even with the Under reporting that we
know men under report this stuff women
are more likely to be abusive than be
abused women are just as abusive if not
more abusive than men um the second
thing that she points out I want you to
see how women view commitment men care
about actions your intentions do not
matter I don't care if you took the vows
and didn't intend to get divorced if you
still got divorced because you saw some
Tik toks sorry this idea that women are
leaving left and right for good reasons
it's just not true most of the time when
women leave it's because they are not
submissive they were not raised to be a
wife and they do not take their vows
seriously they were sold a Disney Dream
that their husband should have
everything and will have no flaws and
are in a gynocentric social order that
tells them they're amazing special and
awesome all the time and never talk
about what they do wrong in a
relationship women overwhelmingly do not
fight for marriages men put up with fat
wives they put up with wives that do not
sleep with them and they put up with
controlling wives all because they care
about the children but women will
divorce men because the man says please
don't go to the club sweetheart or maybe
you don't get your nails done for seven
years notice how in her language she
talks about how getting your nails done
is something you're entitled to even
though she hasn't had her nails done in
seven years ladies why is this stuff so
important why do you feel entitled to
makeup Botox and getting your nails done
once you have a child it's not about you
we live in a me me me me
me world and they forget that really
when you have children you're supposed
to dedicate your life to those children
your feelings don't matter
anymore and women overwhelmingly do not
get a second job even in relationships
that are closer to 50/50 the man still
out earn the women typically um so there
were some comments you know of me just
getting destroyed saying Pearl's just
saying things to be honest and you'll
notice that most of the my critics and
detractors are overweight or older
single women Pearl doesn't think through
what she's even saying no guys I've
actually thought it through completely
if you take a vow that says you are
going to do something you should do it
women do not take it seriously in 2023
they like the idea of marriage but when
it comes to actually doing the hard
stuff they don't stick it out so there
was a woman that actually had a divorce
party let's pull it up Gabby what are we
celebrating
my this this is disgusting it is
absolutely disgusting that you would
celebrate the erosion of a family guys
when you grow up in a single mother home
you are more likely to go to prison you
are more likely to be a rapist you are
more likely to be a mass shooter you are
more likely to run away from home you
are more likely to be enrolled in a
mental institution you are more likely
to drop out of high school every
negative thing in society is linked to
single motherhood and yet women parade
and cheer each other on as they do it
the last woman that was criticizing me
said it's not like when women just do
this for no reason yet we have women
throwing parties about something that is
genuinely sad something that you are
supposed to take seriously how can we
say women are taking this seriously when
we are having parties celebrating it
that [__] is disgusting that is
disgusting in no world should you be
celebrating a divorce and it's
interesting guys notice that the comment
section when it comes from men is a lot
more honest than from women because
women comments tend to cheer the [__] on
or male comments um tend to really tell
you how it is so this guy but tobani
says it doesn't look like she's happy
about the divorce that's how it looks to
me though um another commenter says I
need a follow up in a year to see if she
sounds like Tyrese's ex yes and a lot of
women leave these situations thinking
the grass is greener on the other side
they think that all the men that give
them attention
actually want to date them when really
they just want you for a weekend they
don't want you long term I cannot stress
this enough the majority of single
mothers do not remarry and if they
remarry they are more likely to divorce
than they are to stay with their partner
15% roughly of single moms get remarried
22% get a guy to live with them meaning
60% the overwhelming majority do not
remarry and why does every single mother
think that she is special every child
you have with a man decreases your
sexual market value by at least a point
at least it doesn't matter how
good-looking you are you have two three
kids with another guy you're done don't
expect to remarry and we see this in
real time you know Samantha Lee had no
problems getting divorced from Tyrese
everything seemed good she thought it
was the right decision and last week we
covered that that it in fact was not
good and now she's having second
thoughts and regretting her divorce she
went out there and dated again and
realized the grass probably is not going
to be greener on the other side she puts
out a video saying that she regrets it
and let's see Tyrese's response the the
truth about the matter is that if I had
different people in my ear at that time
it would not have made that
decision look man I was not going to
respond to this video of my ex that's
now gone viral she is loving it
congratulations you went viral again
over something else that you said cuz
you trying to build up your YouTube page
and get your followers up listen man
listen if you had people in your
ear that influenced you into leaving
your husband and your one-year-old child
your innocent one-year-old child we both
were divorce SE kids grew up in toxic
environments torn in between our old
Family new family stepfather stepmother
that's a life that we both
lived and
you packed up a
one-year-old put a CO mask on top of the
Ring cameras and I was literally in an
airplane on my way home to fight for my
marriage and my family you're
heartless and it's been 3
years I've moved on I'm with
zel you moved on I don't even want to
tell [__] the first [__] you started
dating when we broke up cuz you going to
go viral from
that if I were to tell [__] who you
started dating as soon as we broke up
you would go viral from that all you
want is attention you want Facebook
followers you want Instagram followers
you're trying to be a life coach and you
trying to get [__] to drink the
Kool-Aid you [__] with a real one
right
here so a couple things that are
interesting about this clip so he says
if people were to know who you dated
right after me you would go viral so I'm
assuming it's some high-profile guy that
we know that would never commit to her
that she probably thought she could get
commitment from and probably did what
men tend to do with single mother
divorcees which is pass them on to the
next sorry guys this is how men think
and you can shoot the messenger but guys
I interview thousands of men they
typically think that divorcees are for
fun only they don't see them as a
long-term option and the data supports
this most single mothers never remarry
ever most can't even get a guy to live
with them again that is the future
this woman is asking for 20K a month to
raise a child what on Earth do you need
20K a month for I bet he would be fine
with two grand that should cover all
expenses even three I bet you he would
even do
five that that can get you a one-bedroom
apartment and pretty much any major city
and I and I even think that's a bit
extreme I I think if you choose to leave
a marriage then you should have a plan
to financially support yourself and the
child rest of your life no I do not
think that you should be able to depend
on the guy that you are no longer giving
anything in return to I believe that is
legal robbery and I think women that are
legally robbing men should be treated as
such criminals
criminals the third thing he pointed out
is that her mother was in her ear and
ladies this is a tough pill to
swallow a lot of
your mothers do not want to see you
succeed they want to see you just as
miserable as them so you can be her
emotional tampon the rest of her life
because a lot of your mothers have
failed again and again and again in
relationships and they do not want to
see you succeed there are mothers that
are simultaneously telling their
daughters that they love them and
support them while trying to ruin their
marriage this is common I would say this
is more common than it is not